novak djokovic has won his seventh
wimbledon men's singles title in the
past few minutes uh beating nick curios
in four sets four six six three
six four
seven six in the final it is of course a
21st grand slam uh title for
novak djokovic so that leaves him one
behind rafael nadal's all-time record of
22. we can join skies uh jackie beltran
who has the latest now from wimbledon
so what an incredible final so very
entertaining and what a part nick curios
played in that if there were any nerves
from the grand slam debutant we never
saw them he settled right into this
final against novak djokovic took the
first set played some trick shots had
some incredible serving prince george
loved all of it the second set though
novak djokovic seemed to settle a lot
more found his rhythm found his spots
was very calm about the whole thing as
he always is and he took the second set
the third set was very much about nick
curios crumbling and cracking under
pressure chatting away to the umpire
complaining to his box complaining if
they weren't cheering complaining if
they were standing up and cheering i
mean nobody could get it right and it
was a bit of a shame because he was at
times playing some absolutely brilliant
tennis
but he lost the third set and he was
almost out of this final he had to bring
his best to the fourth he had to calm
down after several outbursts and he did
and he so very nearly took it to a fifth
and deciding set it all came down to a
tie break novak djokovic played the
better tiebreak and he is the champion
again
this evening but what do we learn about
nick curios in this final this is his
level he should play more of them